a
[Música]
oposição entre nós o horário Jesus
segurar
Patrícia
parar olha
vamos amiga eu sei que tu quer conversar
eu tenho compromisso eu atrás amanhã
trabalho mas não vou dirigir então da
sua vó da Caixa tá Quê que hoje ele quer
dá trabalho a morena que eu quero tá em
outra esquecer para mim não é nenhuma
missão a mulher mais famosa que eu já
olhei sem roupa passar trabalhar o
fígado mais do que a coração Aquele
olhar o jogo Sei lá só sei que eu quero
beber Então vamos merda
preservar Olá som de ser o que tu tá
sentindo muita dor no coração
gelado bom com você o caminho que você
já estão todos então entornar batons
ligação bota pra descer bota para ser
Bora baixar faz tempo que for lá tem eu
vou procurar fala para vencer botava
machucar fogão toca aquela da morena teu
chora
aparecer volta vaso a bater boca e vou
lá tem eu vou lhe procurar Pode parecer
botava machucar toca aquela da morena
teu chora
Solon
emissor
pegada de vaqueiro
e como é que olhar juro que
eu quero beber Então vamos se ver
só
descer eu quero tá sentindo dor é legal
lado bom levantar com você se você já
entrou 12 Doll entrar na Amador ligação
bota para descer ser Bora apagar até
poder falar tem eu vou lhe procurar
ser voltar para machucar toca aquela da
morena eu chorar [ __ ]
o tempo que vou bater eu vou lhe
procurar volta pra descer bota pra
machucar eu como fazer o resto essa
morena pai chora demais
E aí
e vai segurar na potência
pentear
para conectar
[Música]
o Whindersson Nunes
hahaha ha
[Música]